but you think Russell Wilson jr. the
Third's first ever job paying job was
Paulie paying job paying job caddy at a
local golf course
he's down south I think Virginia he grew
up Richmond athletic family yeah
possibly a nice neighborhood I don't
really know his background but caddy at
age 13 14 Seaton I was gonna say caddy
but nodding we're not saying like a
paper route or something like that right
first job where he was paid anyway
officially paid not like a lemonade
stand
cuz delivering papers that was a lot of
people's first actual job so just so I
don't mind my I really wanted to say
caddy but I'll say delivering newspaper
all right McLovin Russell Wilson's first
job I'm going lifeguard and that's where
he developed like his confidence at the
line of scrimmage yelling yelling at
those kids get out of the pool that led
to like him able to calm lays in the
other face yeah boy what if it's the
Seahawks what if we're all wrong and his
first paying job was being the
quarterback of the Seahawks like he just
never well let's find out firstly do you
have a say he worked in a shoe store and
seems like a footlocker well so Wilson
wearing the officials the referees
Jersey joining us now is Russell Wilson
the Seahawks quarterback first paying
job was what Russ first first paying job
was actually babysitting first paying I
was like the first real thing obviously
mowing along kind of thing but whatever
but real job that I had consistently
actually was actually babysitting for
this family called the lockers and then
I'm really close with still today
what was the like when you work for
somebody else like a business did you
have any job like a paycheck that you
got all the first business I worked for
like you know it was probably um I'm
trying to think his first business I
worked a little like baseball shop thing
actually where I got to teach lessons
and everything else that was kind of
cool so you know babysitting out through
the baseball lessons and then I would
say that first like real real job was
actually uh I was actually a Colorado
Rockies when they drafted me no no real
check congratulations on the new check
coming in the new contract now
you get the first check from the new
contract oh man month or so or a couple
of couple weeks maybe even maybe I'm
shorter than that is it direct deposit
yeah I do direct deposit okay all right
I just I think you should have one of
those big checks you know when the
lottery winners they hold up the big
check so you and Sierra they're you're
holding up that big check
and letting people know that you you
know you're the highest paid player in
the NFL I had my first check actually
but when I signed at somewhere I gotta
find it but I have it filed away
somewhere from when I first found with
the Seahawks and when I had the second
one when I did a second deal and you
know I had I had that pay stub which is
pretty cool so yeah that's a good idea I
may have to save this one I also have
the contract that actually signed and
this time too as well so I saved that as
well so those are like just cool little
memories you have and I'm not I'm
actually not what I wanted to keep a
bunch of stuff I know I keep I have my
first touchdown pass move your phone a
little bit there Russ you're you sound
like you're underwater okay now they're
right there that's okay don't move don't
move okay so what I was saying though I
have my first I had my first touchdown
pass to Sidney Rice I have that saved
and then I have my first NFL whenever
against the Cowboys I have that as well
a few other things as well but I usually
don't keep a bunch of stuff I remember
being told this story that Pete Carroll
was shooting hoops and this is how you
found out that you were gonna be the
starting quarterback with the Seahawks
did were you summoned outside and Matt
Flynn was gonna be the starting
quarterback and Pete Carroll was
shooting hoops by himself and then told
you then that you were going to be the
starting quarterback is that true
parking lot like he's he's playing
street ball he's seen threes inches he's
tunas gob you know he seemed pretty
go up on his own but nobody in front of
them and he come on out here and so he
had one of the guys come get me and I go
outside he says listen you know shoot
some hoops
I said I'm my coach it goes hey listen I
want to let you know that you're going
to be the franchise quarterback for the
Seattle Seahawks and you need a starter
I was just I was just fired up and
saying he goes I and I get dad would be
proud
no it's all hard-working have you done
so that's an ethic memory I always
always always always forever forever
remember I have a theory here and it's
when you went on Jimmy Fallon show and
my theory is you know the producer will
always talk to you before you're going
on to say what do you want to talk about
hey Jimmy was gonna ask you about this
I'm guessing my theory is you had a
chance either you or your agent to say
to Jimmy Fallon's producer hey why don't
you bring up my contract maybe bring up
the Giants me wanting to play here stir
it up a little bit
being the highest-paid quarterback
player in the game am I on to something
there Russ the talk today you know I
don't think that happened is everywhere
I think you know obviously that was part
of the conversation and everybody wanted
to talk about that at that moment I
think that's that's you know I just
don't know you know some egos you know I
say do you want you want to talk about
anything I said look son I'm open book
whatever you guys want to talk about
let's have fun and wait and they didn't
really bring that up and in terms of a
space area but I think I think you know
and I think the thing is what I really
talked about is actually the front drill
we did you know we actually did the
glowing uh that's really what we talked
about the most I walk me through what we
were going to do and they had done that
with Drew Brees and Brett Favre and
wanting to throw footballs at plates and
food and all that so that was actually
awesome so we never actually physically
walked through that part we actually
talked about doing that and they were
wondering about for us yeah let's do it
you know so I was fired up about that
there was a report or leash there was
speculation that that you were gonna
maybe relocate or try to get out of
Seattle and play for the Giants so your
wife could have more opportunities in
New York and you clear that up
[Music]
well congrats on the new contract it's
great and we look forward to the
upcoming season with what Seattle has in
store and you with that new contract
Thank You Ross that's Ross Wilson
Fritzie Xena's cone of silence now we we
apologize yeah because it's now a
punishment well I thought maybe he would
talk to Ross and that's why I brought
down the cone of silence so he could
talk to him and just say you know hey
phone connection wasn't great there yeah
we gotta call our people up at AT&T and
get that guy a fresh well I don't know
if he had the headset on because he kept
sort of fading in and out I thought he's
picked up a job as a court stenographer
with a little bit ignore they're afraid
they're talking about yeah I think
happens sometimes I think I put a lot of
thought into this over the years of our
crappy phone lines yeah
I think that people are talking on their
cell phone and they are sort of doing
this cuz they're home they put it on
their chin and their shoulders and
they're sort of at home talking like he
doing stuff with their kids or whatever
and
this messes everything up that's my
theory well I like their cheek gets over
the microphone area actually blocks it
yeah but it felt like he was moving and
then it was decent and then it was
really bad yeah cuz he's probably trying
to get breakfast ready or something he's
got a bunch of papers that he's
shuffling around or something so he just
doesn't chin the cheek thing with their
phone probably breakfast in bed with
Sierra which he should be every morning
yeah yes yes boy and we're sitting here
thinking after you asked the question by
the Giants during the the part you could
hear what are we saying you know what
des and I really wanted to be in New
York giant but it didn't work out so
well so I'm gonna play with this out the
string here in Seattle we yes it seems
like sometimes ask the questions get a
little more thought provoking or
controversial all of a sudden it
conveniently doesn't sound as clear the
responses is it your fault or my fault I
don't think it's either one of us but I
spoke with him before but we put him on
as I always do and during the duration
that time it's not a time people are
saying Russell was in the cone of
silence yes four more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR Live or
download the Dan Patrick show app